Based on the book by Chuck Pala--
Palani--
Pala--
I'm not gonna pronounce that.
Comes the film that inspired an entire generation
... Of college dorm room posters.
Fight Club.
We're totally about to break the first rule,
aren't we?
Meet Tyler Durden --
I mean "Jack," or whatever.
He's a normal guy with a steady job, nice
condo, and plenty of free time...
Which in the late 90's, meant something was
horribly wrong with your life.
Everything will change when Jack creates the
impossibly cool alter ego of Tyler Durden,
a porn splicing, soup pissing, soap making
badass
who's basically the Che Guevara of imaginary
friends.
Follow Jack/Tyler on their quest to save us
from all of our first world problems.
"Advertising has us chasing cars and clothes,
working jobs we hate so we can buy sh*t we
don't need."
As they tear down our society of mindless
consumer slaves
By building a society of mindless actual slaves.
"Like a monkey ready to be shot into space."
But since he's so hot, barely anyone will
realize he's a total hypocrite.
Aaaaaaaabs.
Enter their secret underground world of fight
clubs,
The only place for modern men to release their
violent urges
Except for boxing,
wrestling,
football,
mixed martial arts,
gun ranges,
action movies,
video games,
hunting,
mosh pits,
hardcore hip-hop,
and war.
Strip down and join in their out of control
punch fests
And their anarchy obsessed terrorist group
Where the only thing they love more than violence
and chaos
is following the rules.
"The first rule of Fight Club is you do not
talk about Fight Club."
"Sir, the first rule of Project Mayhem is
you do not ask questions, sir."
"The second rule of Fight Club"
"The third rule of Fight Club"
"Fourth rule"
"Fifth rule"
"Sixth rule"
"Seventh rule"
"The first rule of Project Mayhem"
"Sir, the first rule of Project Mayhem"
"SHUT UP!"
Take a break from all the sweaty guy-on-guy
action to experience some of your OTHER repressed
fantasies, like...
threatening your boss,
blowing up buildings,
sticking your d*ck in crazy,
punching Jared Leto in the face,
and littering...
Lots and lots of littering.
Take THAT, society!
Then, prepare yourself for a twist ending
we all should have seen coming...
"We're the same person?"
"That's right."
where the movie does everything it can to
show you that Tyler isn't real.
"We have the exact same briefcase."
"Sometimes Tyler spoke for me."
"For some reason, I thought of my first fight
with Tyler."
"Who are you talking to?"
"Shut up."
"This conversation --"
"Is over."
"-- is over."
But nothing to explain why shooting yourself
in the face gets rid of him.
"Are you alright, sir?"
"Oh, yeah, I'm ok."
Are you, though?
So revisit this high-budget Hollywood movie
with an anti-capitalist message, yet features
tons of product placement,
a spin-off PlayStation game,
a graphic novel sequel,
two collector's editions.
and, of course, officially licensed soap.
I am Jack's missing sense of irony.
Starring...
Brad's Pit ts
Stop Hitting Yourself, Stop Hitting Yourself
The Corpse Bride
Dallas Fighters Club
Mewwwwwbs
and Happy Feet.
Fight Club
"With your feet in the air and your head on
the ground"
Like this video if you downloaded this Pixies
song off Napster.